For its fourth installment, the Insidious
franchise takes another step back in time.
We see one of Elise Rainier's earliest childhood
experiences with the other side—and then
we see her as a full-grown ghost-hunter who's
made to revisit her past in cruel and surprising
ways.
While the story is mostly a standalone adventure
for the spiritual psychic, The Last Key still
draws on the mythology of the series, and
features some of the central players of the
franchise in fun and fresh new ways.
Let's take a look at how Insidious: The Last
Key explores Elise's devastating backstory
and wraps things up on a note of continuity.
Pattern of possession
In childhood, Elise is tormented by more than
just the spirits that occupy her family home.
Her prison guard father is also heavy-handed
with punishment, to the point of abuse.
Clearly deranged, he insists he can beat the
ghostly visions out of her and fears her supernatural
gifts.
Summoned back to the property in her later
years by the home's new occupant, Ted Garza,
she discovers he's kidnapped and tortured
a woman in the basement for months.
He claims something has invaded his mind…
"He's in my head."
But he's still ultimately done away with by
Specs.
Afterwards, Elise continues to explore and
uncover more terrible secrets about the history
of the home, including her own father's similar
abduction and slaughter of a woman in that
very spot.
Elise realizes both men were possessed by
the demon that terrorized her in her youth,
and instead of getting revenge on her ghost
dad in The Further, she decides not to feed
the demon herself.
It's not clear that all of her father's bad
behaviors were due to the demonic force, but
he does apologize to her in ghost form before
withering back into his spiritual cell.
Weapon of love
The true big bad of the movie is the key monster.
Elise first runs into it in childhood after
her father banishes her to the basement, with
a voice summoning her to a keyhole that unlocks
the door to the demon's lair.
Her mother is the first true victim of that
mistake, as she attempts to rescue Elise from
the basement but is instead strangled by the
nefarious spirit while Elise remains in a
state of demonic hypnosis.
Her mother's passing is a tragedy for Elise
and her brother.
A warm and loving parent, she'd given him
a whistle to blow if he ever felt scared of
Elise's sightings.
As we see in Elise's older years, the whistle
was lost for decades—but it pops up during
her return to the old home, and it's used
by tortured spirits to guide her throughout
her battle, since the key demon deprives his
victims of the ability to speak.
"Shhhh…"
When Elise confronts the demon in its lair,
it outmaneuvers her and deprives her of her
voice, too.
But she finds the whistle in time to summon
the spirit of her mother, who's able to vanquish
the beast through the sheer power of her love
and light.
It's not clear if Elise's mother will ever
escape the otherworldly prison below that
house, but she does seem at peace when Elise
departs.
Coaching herself
One of the most surprising encounters Elise
experiences during her time in The Further
is when she runs into herself as a child in
the basement.
She doesn't tell the child version of herself
who she is, but does insist that young Elise
use her gifts to help people, despite her
father's tyrannical treatment.
If only she'd been able to tip off the child
that the girl she spots in the laundry room
at the age of 16 is very real, she might have
been able to save Anna.
Alas.
She does at least encourage her to use her
nightmares for the betterment of the world—and
to never back down from demons, otherworldly
or otherwise.
The family business
Although Elise's brother is none too thrilled
to see her again, decades after she'd escaped
their father's menacing clutches, he doesn't
have a choice but to welcome her once she
rescues his daughters.
After Elise informs Christian that she found
his old whistle in the home, he decides the
relic is important enough to track down.
Problem is, his youngest daughter Melissa
is summoned down to the basement by the key
demon, who makes short order of adding Elise's
niece to its collection of victims.
Elise senses the attack and returns to the
property, promising to find her.
After she's temporarily incapacitated below,
though, the other sister Imogen decides to
try her own hand at psychic work and is lulled
into a state of hypnosis by Tucker and Specs.
"I can see things too."
She's there on a rescue mission, but it's
Elise who ultimately leads the two girls back
to safety, and Christian is grateful for her
salvation of his daughters.
Meanwhile, Imogen has now tapped into her
own paranormal gifts, and Elise's legacy can
maybe live on through another generation.
And that's very, very important to the franchise
as a whole because the movie finishes with
a direct link to the timeline of the original
Insidious movies.
Elise dreams about a boy named Dalton being
haunted by the red-faced demon we came to
know so well in the earlier installments and
sees Renai [like "Renee"] and Josh, lying
in bed and lamenting the unknown that's troubling
their child.
Elise awakens to receive a call from Lorraine,
who reminds her that she helped her son Josh,
as we saw in the flashback events of Insidious
2, and now the same thing is happening to
Dalton.
That's the catalyst for the events of the
first Insidious, of course, when Elise helps
Dalton escape from The Further, only to be
strangled by Josh, who's been possessed by
the same demon that haunted him as a child.
Insidious 2 left off with Elise still working
her demon-battling magic, following Tucker
and Specs to new spectral assignments.
But with the added element of Imogen, a new
medium who can work with Elise from the earthly
plane, the ghostbusting business might not
be done for the Insidious team just yet.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!